you
Roman Lacombe is a man on a mission
evolutions an environmental issue but
most of all it's a health crisis more
than 5 million people die every year
from pollution related illnesses Roman
wants to change that he has designed a
system to help humans learn more about
the air they breathe and he did it in
the most unconventional way imaginable
using pigeons wearing tiny backpacks I
will never look at pigeons ever again
like it is before
[Music]
Londyn like many cities as a problem
pollution it's so bad here
it kills nearly 10,000 citizens a year
the problem bogs the weather and
pollution is they interact together and
sometimes create episodes of very high
pollution London weather is notoriously
fickle and pollution levels change with
the weather rains wash up pollutants and
winds sweep them away
Roman wanted to make the invisible
visible to do that he found a way for
people to know when the air is
particularly toxic enter the pigeon air
patrol the pigeon air patrol is
brilliant
crazy idea to fly a flock of pigeons
over the City of London with tiny little
backpacks measure air pollution Roman
outfitted a flock of 10 birds to fly
around London to monitor air quality in
real time they wore special backpacks
equipped with sensors to measure
pollutants like ozone and nitrogen
dioxide and they weren't just ordinary
birds they were highly trained racing
pigeons we worked with Brian experts
pigeon fancier who's been very widely
recognised in the field is a
professional pigeon the race they know
how to always home back to their home
base we had an entire patrol of pigeons
Coco Norbert Julius
[Music]
when the pigeons took to the sky the
data they collected was instantly
accessible to anyone on the ground
citizens could tweet the pigeon Air
Patrol and the nearest backpack sensor
would respond with readings from low to
extreme thanks Edith people tuned in to
know when the good time to go running
and when you can bite without worrying
of a pollution or when you should really
think extra care about the air debris
the pigeon air patrol was just the
starting point so of course the pigeon
Air Patrol was not fixing pollution in
London but by bringing attention from
everyone about this topic we make it
easier for citizens to demand change and
so we make it easier for everyone
involved to say there's an issue there
we should recognize it should address it
and then we can fix it
[Music]
you